rise and shine it's aunt spresso time
good morning belief nation it's seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have an amazing gift
inside you that I want to see explode
out into the world
so grab your coffee and sip on today's
message work passionately on your craft
over to you Dwayne the rock Johnson I
think a lot of people look up to in
terms of a role model for achieving your
ambitions sure what is your advice for
people watching this going I want to do
that thing I love the way that you do
this how do I go about doing it was your
Golden Rule I don't know if there's a
golden role I can tell you this that I
believe anything is possible right I
live in the world of possibility and I
also believe that anything we can
accomplish anything with our two hands
and just putting in the work with our
two hands and also you hear this often
but it's really really true you got to
find something if you love what you do
and find and be passionate about what
you do and find something that you could
be passionate like it really helps you
know it gives you that motivation when
you wake up in the morning doing things
that you love is the number one most
important rule as an entrepreneur in my
new book the top 10 was a success I
looked at the 40 most popular top tens
that I've ever done on the channel and
the number one most consistent rule is
you have to do the thing that you love
you hear it over and over and over and
over again and yet so many people are
just chasing the opportunity the reason
why so many businesses fail and shutdown
is because the owner didn't really ever
have massive passion for that business
they didn't really want to understand
that they just saw it as an opportunity
let's go all-in on Bitcoin because it's
hot even though I have no idea what
bitcoins all about they follow just the
trend and the opportunity and then they
fall flat in their face and they lose
all their money and that's not what I
want to have happen for you you have to
do the thing that you love so if I look
at this business as an example if I look
at YouTube and what I'm making here I
love making YouTube videos today is
gonna be a full day of filming we're
making 25 big videos and then some micro
videos yesterday was also a filming day
for me and they did a hundred micro
videos I never adjusted my schedule that
every week I'm making about a hundred
micro videos the only gap that I had in
my schedule yesterday was to do a half
hour YouTube mastermind call with some
friends of mine who are also full-time
youtubers and I'm on this call with them
and they were asking about potentially
extending our call from half an hour to
an hour
we wanted to not feel so rushed in our
call they wanted to have better bonding
between us get to know each other a
little bit more and I told them guys I
don't think I can do it this is my only
break break I've got to make a hundred
micro videos today I don't know that I
could lose another half an hour I love
you guys I want to learn more about you
but it can't take up my time during my
filming day and they looked at me like I
was crazy that I was making 100 micro
videos that day and they're youtubers
too like their full-time there in the
industry that I'm in but they can't
understand the crazy work ethic and the
amount that I put in to making each
video happen and their model is a little
bit different too but just imagine me
now talking to people who don't get
YouTube but for me waking up and doing
that is not work like I love it I love
watching the clips I love doing the
research I love talking to the ponies I
love creating the content for you guys I
love doing the tests and split testing
titles and thumbnails and strategy I
love it I love everything about it it
fills me up so working the entire day
and my only break being a mastermind
call isn't work it's awesome and it's
the same thing in working here at
Charlie dance salsa in working with Lily
to help her build her business and
working with the investments and
entrepreneurs that I have in my network
I love it now not every day is amazing
and not every piece of every day is
amazing either but net-net
I love the work that I do which allows
me to work really hard and allows me to
get results and that's the same thing
across anybody who's that success you
don't find super successful people doing
things that they hate they love what
they do the people at the top in any
field love what they do and the minute
that I stopped loving YouTube as an
example that's a minute when I know I
have to abandon this channel and go do
something else that I love because if
you do not love what you do and you're
just chasing the opportunity the people
who love it will crush you they're gonna
put in way more work than you they're
gonna get way more skilled than you and
they're gonna win and that's fine let
them win at that cuz you're gonna be
over here we need to know what you love
to do so the question of day today is
I'm curious what is that thing that you
love to do what is the thing that you go
all-in on and when you're
you get lost in it you spend hours and
you don't realize how much time has
flown by because you just love us so
much what is that thing leave it down in
the comments below I also want to give a
quick shout out to Vince Reed Vince
thank you so much for having me on your
podcast or picking up copies of my books
I really really appreciate the support
man and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of n spresso
when you see mark become the Joker when
he's actually in the recording booth and
doing these voices he actually
physically kind of twists himself and
manifests himself into Joker mark
something I think he actually is Joker
so he just turns up and he just nails it
in fact we rewrote all about them to
refit into where he was taking joke one
of the things that informs the Joker is
his laugh I remember reading the comic
books it was ha ha ha ha ha ha but lots
of ho ho his laugh should be like a
musical instrument it should sort of
illustrate his mood it could be ominous
and intimidating he could be gleeful and
wild abandon it but I didn't want to
just have one row laughs I was writing
in the first recording session thinking
how did I laughs I'm out on the freeways
in LA in Los Angeles that's not it no
that's not it
now I'm sure no one in Los Angeles would
look twice at something look at that guy
laughing maniacally his car it's
actually really fun to watch him perform
the character because all of the other
actors are all seated and Mark has to
stand to do it and he gets his whole
body into it they used to kid me because
I was the only one who would stand up
yes
this is all tremendously boring they had
these little you know those separators
that you see like for musicians so your
sound doesn't bleed into other people's
mics and everybody's sitting down at
their little music stand and I just
thought to energise the character to
shake my fist and I felt I've got to
stand up what do you think we can do
about that well you don't have a lot of
free time to do other stuff do you no I
don't have there been situations where
there was something that you really
wanted to do movie wise or any other any
other part that you just weren't able to
do because of your schedule yeah it's
come up a couple of times but that's the
commitment you make particularly when
you're doing a network show is you you
kind of have to be willing to let some
other stuff go and it's helped me to
really focus so that the projects that I
do during hiatus like the movie I'm
gonna do this season it's something I'm
really really passionate about because I
only have one window to do something
else so it has to be something that
really means a lot to me Black Hawk Down
or any of those films we worked on
nobody asked us to Black Hawk Down I
remember being up for 72 hours nobody
asked me to be up for 72 hours and was
trying to do something extraordinary
trying to tell a story in an
extraordinary way trying to you know the
a band of brothers you know not let
anybody else down that was on your team
it's not superhuman its human at the the
unfortunate thing is that you have to
put the word super in front of it when
it's it's the ambition it's it's what we
should all strive for you know that that
commitment to the gesture to the love to
the how we approach today how we
approach each other how we approach
humanity how we approach art and beauty
and ultimately in Martin's case how we
approach our instrument you know there
needs to be respect
when you give you the 1/1 supermodels
one was long you have the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be kind
of like a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details